yeah hello and welcome to this
announcement video yeah I hope all of
you had a good christmas time or still
have in Germany we still have the second
day of Christmas I don't know how it is
in other parts of the world so today is
still a holiday in Germany but I don't
think it sounds like this everywhere so
I hope you have a good time and this
video is about to live streams that i'm
going to do i did not manage to do some
on the Christmas days but instead i'm
going to do to live streams around yeah
the style of the new year so the first
one will be on after look it up so don't
screw of the details the first one will
be on New Year's Eve on the Vista as we
say in Germany and it will be at three
in the afternoon central european time
makes it 9am US East Coast I know it's
rather ready but it's a good time for
the european guys this will be playing
blitz on d chess my mom teaches here
learn to play blitz only chance against
them channel subscribers or yeah people
who are in the chat of that live stream
on youtube so ok i might play the otter
other challenge but if you are in there
in the chat channel i'm going to play um
to any reasonable it's time control um
this would be on New Year's Eve and I
also will do something on New Year's Day
this will be a little bit later this
will be in the evening central european
time seven in the evening which makes it
what is that this is like yeah 1 p.m.
eastern east coast time in the US so i
think it's a reasonable time even on new
year's day to play and this will not be
blitzes will be a simultaneous event i'm
going to play roughly 20 players please
stop the drilling roughly 20 players
also only chest I have to check out the
time control probably something like
yeah I do 60 + 60 60 minutes 60
second increment on the simians for our
sec something like that would have to
figure it out it depends how long this
takes I might even play some glitz
afterwards we'll see so there will be
two interesting and entertaining a hope
live streams around the start of the new
year yeah open your um be able to join
i'll post the links here in the text
description of this video yeah thanks
for watching